selena gomez gets candid about social
media admitting that instagram is quote
dangerous for her even revealing why she
never felt quote pretty enough while
using it i like to choose to live my
life in a way where i want to be weight
free i think it is important to kind of
go through your life the way you want
the 29 year old triple threat opens up
inside the february issue of instyle
magazine revealing that in her early 20s
she felt like she wasn't pretty enough
and quote at one point instagram became
my whole world and it was really
dangerous
but selena says that as she got older
she realized she needed to take control
of what she was feeling so she took a
break from social media something she
says was the best decision she ever made
for her mental health quote i created a
system where i still don't have my
passwords and the unnecessary hate and
comparisons went away once i put my
phone down i'll have moments where that
weird feeling will come back but now i
have a much better relationship with
myself my personal life and my family
and my friends i'm just i'm in a really
happy place it's been good the good for
you singer adds that she's a big
believer in therapy and feels the most
confident when she's taking care of
herself i'm just so confident and
comfortable and i feel free more than
i've ever felt in my whole life i feel
comfortable in my skin you know
quote i have to make sure that i'm okay
you know because if i'm not okay i can't
be okay for other people i'm constantly
somebody that likes to grow and feel
like all right what could i be better at
what could i do better at work
where could my confidence be stronger
and all that self-love seems to be
paying off i am so excited 2022 is
shaping up to be a huge year for the
texas native who landed a critics choice
awards nomination for her role in only
murders in the building alongside steve
martin and martin short
we should do our own true crime podcast
we're going to go down there and look
around for clues you want to come
do i want to break into a dead guy's
apartment and go through all his [ __ ]
sounds like an afternoon i could barely
keep a straight face just hanging out
with them it was so wonderful and i
learned so much being around them
they're legends in their own right but
they've you know they're good people
humble funny kind and professional and
it was just the best
she's currently hard at work filming
season two of the hit hulu show this
time with her close pal cara de levine
i'm so happy it's so sweet and get this
selena and cara are so tight they even
got the same watercolor rose tattoo last
month it was great it was really really
fun selena on her upper back
cara on her rib cage it's nice it's
really nice but back to selena the
singer just reached a major milestone
scoring her first grammy nom for her
spanish language album revelation
[Music]
and when it chatted with cell last month
she opened up about the high honor i
cried of like a little baby i was very
excited
and i worked really hard on that project
so it was
a lovely surprise i'm very excited
[Music]
you